welcome everyone um my name is candace
rogers i'm the co-director of the
canadian institutes for advanced
research child and brain development
program
for those of you who might be unfamiliar
with cfar it's a canadian-based global
research
organization that convenes leading
scholars to address some of the most
pressing questions
that are facing humanity and science so
the cdbb
program which i co-direct brings
together experts from across
medicine psychology genetics and machine
learning to advance the science of child
development
and develop new tools and approaches for
ensuring all children can thrive
i'm fortunate today to be joined by my
colleague in cbd mike cabor
mike is a professor at the university of
british columbia he also directs the
social expo zone cluster at ubc
where his research focuses on human
population epigenetics
or the dynamic interplay between genes
and the environment
and also by megan azad who's a fellow in
cfar's
humans in the microbiome project and
studies the developmental origins of
health and disease of the
university of manitoba so megan is also
a renowned
expert in infant nutrition and the role
of the microbiome
in child health and development so both
mike and megan who are canadian research
chairs
and they're involved in some of the most
innovative research right now
in canada tracking children through the
coven 19 pandemic so we're fortunate to
have both of them with us today
now the three of us are also part of a
larger group
that's a project that's entitled the
hidden costs of covet 19 for children
this has been supported through cfar
through the manulife
cfar population health and well-being
program and this was announced earlier
this year in response to the global
pandemic and so what we're going to do
for the next 30 minutes is we're going
to have a bit of a discussion
that outlines the potential costs of
covert for children
and how cfar in this team is positioning
to respond to this
we welcome all of our audience members
to participate we welcome you to
insert your questions to the q a
function at the bottom of the screen so
the chat features have been disabled
but if you'd like to ask a question
please enter it there and we'll try to
get to as many questions
as possible throughout the discussion so
i want to start off by just
talking with each of you mike and megan
about your
the work and the foundation that has led
to this
project so mike first with you i think
when kova 19 started
many people thought or saw that children
were being physically spared
from the disease but in the in that
project outline
what you state is that the copenhagen
experience
can still become biologically embedded
and can still disrupt important aspects
of brain functioning
immune functioning and children's
ability to thrive
can you tell us a bit more about this
and how the team is positioning to
address some of these issues
during the pandemic yeah sure can this
sense for having me be part of this
really important uh conversation
i think what we realized some long time
ago
um is that really the um social
environment
of in which we live in can get
as we call under the skin to affect
biology and health and can do so
potentially in a lifelong
fashion and so when um kovit came along
and you know luckily
um our children for most part are spared
from the sort of direct physical effects
we realize that
all of these really well intended public
health consequences
and the societal changes that really go
hand in hand
with covert or heft and handing and with
the pandemic
can have potentially unintended
consequences
that are very deeply rooted in what we
understand about the biology of early
child development and in particular
these can be things like increased
stressors for children and adolescents
that
you know can have profound impacts and
and just to name a few
uh that we know from from a large body
of research
um prior research things like reduced
family income
um food insecurities stress
in families among parents um raging all
the way to potential
child abuse and spousal abuse that
children might experience
lack of access to outdoor spaces all of
these things can leave a biological
residue
and really these massive shocks can get
under the skin of our children and stick
with us and there's a there's a whole
range of really interesting biology uh
candice you alluded to
um things like the immune system brain
development
all of these physiological processes can
be affected
by these by these social environments so
that's really sort of at the heart of
where this proposal uh
is rooted um and the idea then is
can we now measure directly in
children that are exposed to these
current pandemic conditions
um whether these predictions that we
know from from this large body of
research that's
really become way before covet um and
that's where for example the work that
we had proposed in the manual life
sifa uh proposal that also then
intersects with what megan of course is
doing on the on the canadian
child card yeah so this is interesting
most discussions about children have
really focused on school openings and
not bio
biology or long-term consequences in
other aspects so this will be important
um megan um you are involved in two
pretty large scale studies right now the
the child study the code of child study
and also a study that's looking at
pre-term birth during the pandemic so
what are some of the kind of questions
you're coming into this with and how
does it frame kind of how you think
about working with the larger team
on these issues yeah so mike mentioned
the child study and
the importance of looking at long-term
impacts and so the child study is a
national canadian birth cohort study
it's actually been ongoing for more than
a decade so we enrolled 3 500 families
with
children born between 2010 and 2012 and
we've been following them ever since
collecting loads of information about
their home environment
the outdoor environment their nutrition
their mom's nutrition starting in
pregnancy
um stress in the home so really getting
at this idea of stress getting under the
skin biologically
and then we've been collecting
biological samples so blood samples to
look at
stress hormones and genetics fecal
samples to look at the microbiome so you
mentioned at the beginning i'm part of
cfar's microbiome
program and so i'm very interested in
the microbiome how it
forms in infancy and develops over a
lifetime um
and then early on when the children were
infants we looked at things like
breastfeeding and breast milk
but we've been tracking them um for
their whole lifetime and they're now
around
10 8 to 10 years old and so this study
had to be put on hold when the pandemic
hit
because we normally have the families
and children come into our research
institutes
to do different types of tests and
complete surveys
and of course we weren't able to have
that happening earlier in the pandemic
we've been able to resume
visits in a modified way over the summer
but we realized as we were all sitting
at home not being able to do our main
research projects that actually we had
an incredible opportunity here
having so much information about these
children and their parents before the
pandemic
um to collect information on how they're
being affected right now
um living through this experience of the
pandemic and all the measures that come
with it like mike described
and then to embed that in our study
because child is a longitudinal study
and as long as we continue to get
funding we plan to follow these children
until they become adolescents and
young adults so whatever impression this
experience
leaves on them we'll be able to follow
it along into the future
so we were fortunate to get um supported
by the canadian institutes of health
research to launch this study
where we'll be looking both at the
direct impact so if some of the children
or parents in the study do become
infected and develop covid
we'll be able to capture that and ask
questions about you know who got the
most sick
um who did not get sick and had no
symptoms and is there something about
their biology which we know a lot about
from the study
or their um kind of social environment
at home that able
enabled them to be resilient and then
the indirect impact which
you know hopefully not too many children
will contract ovid
but we know all of them are living
through this period of transition and
stress and we'll be able to look at that
in the study
the second project i'm involved in as
you mentioned is looking at pre-term
birth
so this is an idea that blossomed in the
last two months and has really exploded
into a large international study
where we're focusing on the the period
of pregnancy
and looking at whether the experience of
the pandemic again
um is affecting perinatal outcomes so
rates of preterm birth and stillbirth
and how that might be different in
settings like canada versus
low and middle income countries so
that's been a really exciting
new project as well that's incredible
and i'm just thinking about those two
great resources will allow
in canada to track the long-term impacts
as you follow these children over years
and decades
one of the things that we've been
wondering a lot about the child brain
development program
is the impact that this has had on
research the pandemic itself
and how we can continue to collect this
type of valuable data
from children and from families when we
have to remain apart and so mike i know
that your group has been working on some
of this kind of innovation around the
measures can you say a bit about
how your ponies to address this yeah
that's uh that's an excellent point and
making alluded to this that you know
during the pandemic
um and probably for all the right
reasons um
a lot of the sort of cohort uh research
that would take place in hospital or
research institute settings has been
shut down and and so
when this came about um we also realized
that you know
let's make a lemonade out of lemons and
think about how we can perhaps
fundamentally change the way we do
population um child health research and
so for this proposal that we got funded
from the cfa manulife
grant really the key part is to to
develop
what we call a collected home kind of
kit that really would allow us
to send to families
you know all over the place essentially
um so not limited to the usual centers
for biomedical research around big
hospitals or big universities but
including rural spaces and
like a kit by which you can then um
assess
these measures some of these key
biological variables
social variables but also behavioral
data and so um
we're developing this as we speak and
key to this is
really um technology that's being uh
really pushed ahead by a
fellow child and brain development
member atomic date which is the dry
blood spots
that can be easily and very
non-invasively um
be collected anywhere in the world
essentially
and then um many of the epigenetic and
the omix measures that
may alluded to can be derived at very
high quality from these drive blood
spots
but we're also and then this you know is
where for example you
you have been a lot of experienced
candice we're also thinking about how
can we collect a lot of behavioral data
remotely um how can we use you know uh
variables and
mobile devices to really do a very high
quality assessment
of the different environments that a
child might find themselves in so i'm
really excited about this because i
think it really
will uh democratize population research
in many ways it will create
the opportunity to have citizen
scientists families be actively part
of biomedical research and as i
mentioned before
it also has the the huge potential to to
really reach underserved populations
people in
you know families in rural areas that
might be affected by
given environments that usually are not
part of these studies and the like
and and perhaps most importantly i think
this kind of approach is what could
call collected home is really also
adaptable to a variety of situations
we're just thinking about things like
the wildfires right where
we probably have dramatic effects on on
child development as well and if we can
capture
all of this information i think we can
really revolutionize
it the way we do we understand the
factors that affect
healthy child development and how they
might be disrupted by these
environmental shocks that we're
currently going through
so it's interesting to hear about how
this may spur innovation
in terms of reaching families and
children that we might not otherwise
reach in our studies and this is i think
important because one of the things that
we're hearing a lot is about
differential risk or impacts of the
pandemic so
megan in the in the studies that you're
conducting with with families what do
you anticipate
seeing in terms of different impacts so
are all children at risk
from the from the pandemic will some
children suffer more in the years to
come
well first on mike's point i think
collecting samples from home is
something
for example in the child study we've
been saying for years yeah next time
around next
time we do collect data we should do
samples from home but there hasn't been
a big
you know big enough motivation to
actually get it working and this is what
it
what it's come to so i think like so
many things um there are some silver
linings to what's going on
you know in eat health and people being
able to access care remotely when they
weren't able to before because of all
sorts of red tape and barriers
um and that's happening too in research
so this has forced us to get our act
together and figure out how to collect
these samples from home
and that's going to really open up new
opportunities as research
carries on after the pandemic i think in
terms of differential risk
that is something we anticipate seeing
um and because we have such a large
study
covering four different provinces and
you know different strata
socioeconomic status we do anticipate
that
the associations we see won't be the
same for every population group
and so it could be that you know
families who
maybe have had to deal with more stress
earlier in the child's lifetime will be
more resilient to
tackling this pandemic or it could be
that having those stressful experiences
earlier on
have really embedded a more susceptible
profile so those are things that we'll
be able to tackle
in the pre-term birth study a really
interesting example of this is
we really got interested in the study
because there have been some
um reports um in the media
saying that in places like canada the uk
denmark there has actually been a
dramatic reduction in preterm births
during the pandemic um which is
surprising to people because
um that would seem to be a good thing
you have to think a little bit more
about
about it first of all is it a good thing
is there for example more stillbirths
that are
um counteracting that but also once we
started talking to low and middle income
countries they said well that's really
not what we're seeing
um we're seeing an increase and we're
seeing more still bursts and so
really understanding that the pandemic
and the associated lockdowns
and control measures might be affecting
different countries or different
populations within countries in very
different ways
that's right i'm going to remind
everyone that we're approaching kind of
the halfway mark of discussion and so
for those of you in the audience if you
have questions i invite you to kind of
drop them into the
into the q a section now um
and one of the the things that i've been
thinking about um and a question that i
get a lot and i don't know if either of
you have a better answer than i have had
is
um this wonderful research is happening
in terms of thinking about
understanding what the impacts of cobot
are but other things that we know from
the science of child development already
about the impacts of
early adversity about things that might
buffer and protect children in other
similar situations now we haven't had a
global pandemic but we have had
many kind of experiences of children
experiencing adversity
what are some of the um things that we
know from prior developmental science
that that might
inform how we act now as parents as
educators as um as policy makers in
terms of
putting children on the agenda when
thinking about covet 19.
so do either of you have um have
thoughts on that
yeah maybe i sort of picked it up uh
kangas and thanks for bringing it up i
think it's
uh really clear as you said that we we
know
there's a um just an amazing uh
body of biology uh research that has
been done
on these kind of conditions that our
children are experiencing now
um and including um some that um you
know identify clear pathways and
processes that are linked to these um
early life environments and how they get
under the skin so
so i can speak for you know epigenetics
the science of our gene regulation can
speak about the microbiome
um you know there is a lot of work about
long-lasting changes in the immune
system that are um you know associated
with
uh social environments early in life and
i think
some of this research has also been
taken to the next level and i think
that's what you're alluding to in terms
of
how can we potentially buffer up some of
these um
these detrimental effects and then there
is you know evidence that
just having a supportive adult um in in
life might help um to to buffer up some
of the detrimental affected
effects related to so in our case early
life
low socioeconomic status and and and
stresses and so i think
you know we can put it together and
really help um
to provide some guidance to families and
to communities as to how
they perhaps best uh can can deal with
this and i think it was you actually in
one of the operas that we wrote it came
up with this
with this lovely um thing that i just
find so
so um um heartwarming that you know
physical distance doesn't
physical distancing doesn't have to mean
social distancing i think that's
really key um more broadly speaking i
think you know um
we have certainly proposed that policy
makers and the like do
um include scientific evidence of the of
the
kind that we are speaking about here
this morning that they do include
people that understand the science of
early child development the biology of
early child development pediatricians
and then psychologists and all that in
in formulating um responses to how we
best deal
with pandemic pandemics or wildfires and
the like so
great question so we are getting we're
getting a couple questions coming in um
one of them is actually something that
i've worked a lot on so i'll take a stop
at addressing it and that's
what um impact that the digital world
can play at this time
um and i think one of the things that
we're seeing right now is that there are
these huge inequities in terms of how
digital technology is available to
families into
children is playing out as remote
schooling rolls out as telehealth rolls
out so
one of the um kind of immediate policy
implications is ensuring
that every family has the right and the
ability to be connected and have the
supports in place
to kind of reach those resources online
now i know a lot of um
parents and policy makers and teachers
are worried about this increased screen
time
for children um we've done a lot of work
on this and shown that screen time isn't
necessarily
harmful and in terms of that might be a
bit of an overblown concern but at this
point
screens and digital technologies could
be leveraged to reach families and offer
the kinds of social support that you're
talking about mike so when
children are disconnected from teachers
from coaches
from the people in their outside world
how can we leverage or use technology
in kind of good ways to to connect
children and families how can we
mobilize resources to distribute
free and reduced lunch the kinds of
things that come with food insecurity
and those types of and those types of
things um
so the the other thing that um you know
in terms of
buffering the pandemic do you have any
thoughts megan in terms of
very early child development so there's
been concerns voiced
for young children everything from
breast milk which i know that you've
studied
a lot and whether they're their safety
or on that
and also just in terms of the disruption
of children's kind of socialization
during the pandemic
yeah so thinking of very early life and
the time around birth
um research has emerged so rapidly
around everything related to covet and
breastfeeding and breast milk is no
exception so
very early on there was a lot of concern
about you know could breastfeeding
possibly transmit the virus and
therefore if a mom has coveted should
she not be breastfeeding should she step
be separated um
from her newborn immediately at birth to
avoid transmission
um and some hospitals were doing that
early in the pandemic and there was a
lot of concern about that because
there's a lot of evidence showing that
that maternal infant newborn connection
skin to skin contact in the first hours
is what stimulates breastfeeding
and kicks off a lot of important
physiological processes in the newborn
and so there was a lot of concern about
that separation and what long-term
impact it might have and really for what
benefit if there wasn't evidence that
their transmission was occurring or that
newborns were severely affected by the
virus
over time as the evidence has
accumulated um
hospitals have primarily changed their
practices around that the who has now
come with
clear guidance saying that mothers
should not be separated from their
newborn infants
um even if they have covid uh there can
be
ways of you know practice hygiene wear a
mask but breastfeeding is still
recommended
human milk researchers really rallied
together to
study and get an answer to whether the
virus is present in milk
um and the resounding consensus so far
is that it's not transmitted there are a
few samples where
virus has been viral dna has been
detected but it's not
a competent virus that can replicate and
transmit disease
um so where there was some alarm in
question there now seems to be a pretty
clear consensus that
breastfeeding is safe and very much
recommended even if a mom has covet
she's producing antibodies in her breast
milk and that might actually protect the
baby
who might get exposed otherwise in a
household so that has been an area of
concern and that of course links to
the microbiome which develops really
early in life we know how important
breastfeeding is for the microbiome
and that comes back to the issues we've
been discussing already today there's a
gut brain axis
where the gut microbiome is affecting
brain function and the immune system and
all these things that interact to
really program later life physiology and
ability to deal with stress
so i think that early period is really
critical and one of the other manufacts
that i'm a part of is funding research
on exactly that
topic you know how is this physical
distancing affecting the development of
babies microbiome so that's another
really interesting area of ongoing
research
so that leads us to one of the questions
from the audience which is kind of the
opposite effect is the increased
sanitation
uh that we're basically seeing of the
excess of hand washing perhaps what what
that might be doing to the microbiome
in terms of and also in terms of
resistance to disease long term and mike
you might have something to add on this
also but
megan i think this is really in megan's
wheelhouse
yeah so um it's interesting because it
feels like we spent the last couple of
decades trying to
teach everyone that we don't need to
sanitize every surface
um we really have become too clean and
this in a way has harmed our microbiomes
you know these sanitizers and
antibiotics are made to kill
pathogenic bacteria that make us sick
but most of the time they're also
killing the good bacteria that help keep
us healthy
so there'd been a long period of
re-education around
don't over sanitize microbial exposures
are good for a healthy immune system
especially early in life
and then the pandemic hits and all of a
sudden there is a legitimate reason to
be washing our hands more using
sanitizers and so this is a puts us in
an interesting spot we had actually just
published a paper
um about how overuse of household
cleaning products was linked to
higher risk of asthma allergies and um
because of the timing of it we wrote a
letter saying well
in the time of pandemic it is important
to to be careful so
but i think it's an interesting question
kind of will this be a secondary ripple
effect of the pandemic
will people become uber clean again and
what long-term impact that might have
so there was um an interesting article
in science um
yesterday on copenhagen and children
kind of summarizing what we know and i
see that we're getting some questions
about going back to school and about
supporting
young children during this time um and
you know my read of that
that article was you know people have
been concerned about children as
vectors of disease during this time um
in terms of transmission
and it seemed like from what we know so
far the transmission within households
really isn't going upward from children
to adults kind of at a rate that would
be
kind of alarming in terms of spread and
prioritizing getting back to school and
so
um one of the questions is about
supporting young children
during this time and kind of balancing
this trade-off between
safety of bringing children together and
what we
all see and know that they need in terms
of socialization so
um have either of you kind of grappled
with that or
thinking about that in terms of moving
forward with
with the studies i think that's a really
important question you know
i think as we know um there is many good
reasons for
lots of um folks to wear masks
including you know in some schools
but at the same time you know some of
the the younger
children in particular um it might be uh
challenging for them
not only because of the physical sort of
limitation but also
um by the fact that they might not be
able to
really decipher emotions and
interruptions as well as
as they would do without and so i think
it's a really important question and a
a balance that needs to be found between
the safety of all involved including
our teachers students and staff and
schools
and the potential impact on you know um
child development and i think some of
the measures that we have proposed
potentially can help with deciphering
what really matters
in terms of you know these new
environments getting under the skin and
so my hope is that
as we move forward with this research we
might be able to provide some guidance
for these kind of crucial aspects as
well
thanks mike um one of the questions we
have from the audience refers to
um this the differential stress of the
pandemic and the load that it's
placing on women and mothers of young
young children and so
we know that maternal mental health is
actually one of the best predictors of
child health and well-being in the long
term so what are you seeing in kind of
your research and studies about
potential impacts of on maternal mental
health and how
they're faring during the pandemic
so there's a really excellent group of
researchers based out of the university
of calgary that launched a study on
pregnancy in the pandemic really early
on
and have done a great job they've
already had a paper out published last
week
and seen quite alarming increase in
maternal anxiety and depression
in their surveys compared to post
pre-pandemic
which i think probably isn't surprising
um this is a very stressful period and
like you said that could have a really
long-term
impact on the children of those mothers
um
i think um this is also something that
comes into play in our
in our study on pre-term birth um you
know having the lower rates we would
have anticipated maybe people have more
stress we would expect higher rates of
preterm birth
um but then if people are working from
home maybe that's a lower amount of
physical stress um of course you talk to
moms and they go well i have three kids
i'm homeschooling like this is a huge
amount of stress so probably depends on
your home um scenario and this is
something we want to really
dig into in a more detailed way but
certainly stress is a major um player in
all of these research questions right
now
yeah and kind of very quickly i think
you had asked a question earlier about
you know whether
the pandemic will increase uh
inequalities and whether there might be
particularly uh vulnerable groups and i
certainly i think it is exactly the kind
of groups that are already sort of
struggling
that might be in you know shops that
aren't secure that might be
single-family single-parent households
that might
particularly be affected by some of
these detrimental effects of the
of the you know pandemic and getting
under the skin so i think it's a really
important uh perhaps the most important
aspect is that we support
our families and especially those that
are struggling
and that's been a long-standing focus of
the child and brain development program
is focusing on adversity in those
families that are under the greatest
stress and some of our fellows now have
studies that are being launched
following women through pregnancy so
it'll be important to kind of
see what happens as as we follow those
women forward
i see we're approaching the end of time
i want to take a second and thank you
both
megan and mike for joining us and
sharing kind of your work and insights
i want to thank manulife for their
commitment to population health and
well-being research at cfar for now over
30 years and i want to thank our
audience for for attending and
participating so thank you
thanks
you